and look who's in the guest here one of
my favorite people on the planet one of
the great uh rams of all time he eerie
on the rich eisen show in person tori
holt how are you tori anger man good to
see you good to see you man uh
better better to see you here it really
is you're one of my favorite thank you
brother i appreciate it established in
the previous segment that you were one
of the first nfl players i met as the
host of nfl network on the commercial
campaign of
of being rich doesn't suck nfl total
access and i shot you at football
yeah in atlanta where the falcons
wouldn't let you in
to the facilities that's right because
you were an enemy territory you were a
ram this was the uh this was the days of
the old nfc west
where the falcons for some reason were
sitting in the nfc
st louis ranch i wonder why i was
standing out there
it was because they wouldn't let you
know
they would not
they didn't want you to go back to the
rams and tell all the secrets that dan
reeves and michael vick were cooking up
like literally that's how long ago it
was wow that's a long time ago man great
times it is and now you're in town uh
for the sunday night game yeah in town
for the sunday night game okay and uh
really excited about watching the club
and
you know just saw you guys have von
miller on in the press conference he
seems to seems excited hope he plays
tomorrow
uh if he does if he does he'll be
energetic he'll be running wild and uh
so yeah i'm really excited about that
and then my buddy isaac bruce gets his
uh so that's so he's getting his ring he
gets his ring sunday night that's right
yeah against the titans i mean what i
mean what what better way to to do that
against the team because the rams and
titans have played them in superbowl 34.
yeah they've you played a big one you
won that game i know where were you on
the sideline when it was all i was
standing into it i was standing towards
the end with with this with th with this
view the long view the long view okay
and so you had no idea myself isaac and
stan crockett was was right there and
isaac as positive as he is we got this
they gonna make the play we we went in
that's that's what he said this is what
he's saying uh-huh stan's pacing and i'm
looking like okay let's let's watch it
and then we watch it all unfold and
kevin dyson ran the little under out
mike jones had his eye on kevin and
white check i think at the same time
[Music]
and came up and and made the play and
next thing i know we were
off to the races to the football field
confetti is going down and towels are up
in the air live's changing life's
changing changed my life forever all of
us
because but so you were able to tell
even from how far away you were
that it was or you just watched all your
other things just watched everybody else
take this because i couldn't see i
couldn't i couldn't see
to me from my advantage view it really
looked like he may have scored right but
when i seen everybody else take off
oh we won so i just just took off man
and then eventually
saw that he was one yard away from from
scoring but mike jones man the ultimate
pro when i first came into the national
football league
mike jones would be one of the first
guys in the in the building every day
sometimes sometimes he'll come in a suit
in a suitcase or something like like he
had that kind of professionalism about
him and i'm saying to myself if i could
if i can do that if i can do what he's
doing get early train and get myself
prepared then you know i could be the
type of pro that mike jones was so
it was it couldn't happen to a better
dude he prepared for that moment and and
a great great tackling again it changed
the trajectory of all of us all of our
careers and then um isaac bruce is
getting his ring for the pro football
hall of fame on sunday night his hall of
fame speech tory i loved yeah for a
couple of reasons
first of all his message secondly he
hardly said a word yep as a pro that's
correct and he hardly ever
chest pounded ever not saying get me the
ball he never chest pounded get me the
ball and he never chest pounded i am who
i am go inside he was saying get me the
damn ball and then he finally gets in
the hall of fame
and he drops how do you like me now yeah
and how did that land with you his team
i loved it i loved it because again
isaac is not the one to talk or boast
yeah let us play do the talking he can
get nasty though
if you try him he can get nasty and to
me that was an opportunity for him to
say a lot of things that he wanted to
say and obviously that was one of them
how you like me now i think i tweeted it
out how you like me now
you know i did not see
like out of all the things going into
that weekend even with the number of
speeches that there were uh i would have
taken uh i didn't see on on the hall of
fame bingo card isaac bruce quoting
kumodi i did not see that
neither you know
i didn't see it so so he kind of
surprised you with that yeah i mean he
well it showed me the his depth of music
i knew he liked music but it certainly
showed me the depth of his music talent
but
um i think all athletes have something
that drives them
and for isaac we saw
what that was one of the reasons uh that
that drove him to become the player that
he was i had to i had the opportunity to
watch a hall of famer daily from my
rookie year to my until he left um
after our 10th year together
so i saw a pro every single day again
same way i was talking about michael
jones i had the opportunity to see isaac
the same way and i'm thinking if i can
if i can do half of what he's doing or
more mm-hmm
i could be great marshall faulk was in
that room in that building orlando pace
was in that building kurt warner was in
that building yeah brother ray agnew was
in that building so many todd light was
in that building so many guys
in that room in that building when i
came in as a rookie to learn from and
then to see isaac man um
to me i've always said he's the epitome
of an athlete professional athlete he he
did it the right way um he did it with
passion he did it with intent and you
know now we're champions man we go down
in the history books forever
no question about that and just
lingering in the past for for a couple
more minutes with you tori holt you know
kurt's got his movie coming out yeah
about about this
subject matter in his life do we know
who plays you in the film i don't know
tori hall i don't know but i was asked
several times on twitter who should i
say michael b jordan
of course why not why not i mean you got
to go straight up the food chain the
sexiest man going to the highest level
you're not going
you're not going to just go with any
actor i'm going highest level right away
michael b jordan is
but i don't know who that who that who
played but i'll be curious to see how he
moved what he looked like
um
but just outside the kirk man what what
a storybook career
another guy
that that i had the opportunity to right
to see work and be around and and kurt
came in with great intention and man we
rolled bro
we wrote tori holt here on the rich
eisen show what about the current um
team right now it sure looks like they
are
set yes and just in terms of you know
we're talking about von miller and
rightfully so and aaron donald and
jaylen ramsey on offense um cooper cup
just got named offensive player of the
month
second straight month what are you
seeing from him
that makes him so good he's um
he's fantastic he's consistent
he's a uh he's a pro you know i had an
opportunity to sit in the meeting room
with with those guys and what's that
like he and robert woods are in the
front
uh no different than how it was when
when i was in st louis with isaac we
were we were up in the front um notepads
are out pins are out there's questions
being asked there's uh direction been
given and they're and they're taking it
and then not only are they listening
they're going out and applying it on the
football field cooper cup is that uh
he's hella athletic six two i don't know
people know how big cooper cup is yeah i
think they think he's like five ten five
no he's six two two hundred and two
hundred plus
really really good athlete and he has
the ability to get open and he's very
dependable in catching the football he's
on the all he's on my all hands team
which i have my own all hands team who's
on that team he's on that team robert
woods is on that team uh and a mecca
amisi from nc state is on that team and
then obviously moi
is on that team as well um but yeah i
mean cooper cup is
cooper cup is
is fantastic and not only not only
is he dependable catching the football
for he's now catching it long now i
think he has five or six catches for
40-plus yards so he's extending the
field hugely done he's really good on
third downs he's good in the red zone
but what i love
is the fact that they'll mix it up in
the run game to create room for daryl
henderson and sony michelle because they
know the importance of that if they're
blocking well on the perimeter there's
longer runs rich and then what that does
is it sets up the play action pass and
one-on-one situation for them in the
passing game which as receivers we don't
mind blocking now i wasn't a heinz ward
type of a blocker but i was a positional
i would get in position and get a good
block okay
but i knew the importance of doing that
because it would set up the things that
i wanted to do on the perimeter and
that's what you're seeing with cooper
cub robert woods and the emerging van
jefferson and ben scron scaronick from
notre dame mm-hmm uh and and his talent
playing special team so
this football team wide receiver room is
in good shape and it's and it's led by
good men and woods and cooper cup and
cooper cup if not the best in the if not
one of the best in the league the best
receiver right now playing in the game
he has a chance to go over a thousand
yards this weekend rich it's crazy isn't
it it's crazy yo he's which means he's
got calvin johnson in his sights no
doubt even without a 17th game we're
we're you know this is one of the
biggest years of i think in football and
nfl football is we're seeing i mean you
just look at the games and right
and we're getting an opportunity now to
potentially witness more history if he
stays on this path
i think they have a football team that
can do it he certainly has a coordinator
and coach mcveigh who loves him who
wants to get into football hey at the
end of the year we'll we'll see and a
quarterback too stafford must be looking
around saying this is the greatest thing
ever yeah that miller's now von's on the
team like he's part of an aggressive
another stop adding
and and and it's it's remarkable to say
this about a quarterback
in the nfl certainly of stafford's
stature but i don't feel like it's all
on him you know what i'm saying like
even though it kind of is we know it is
i agree but i just don't get the sense
like it's all on him right i'll agree i
i totally agree and
with henderson in the backfield again
with sony michelle the wide receiver the
tight end higbee right solid offensive
line whitworth one of our better leaders
in all the football and certainly on
this team and he's such a
just just plays at a high level he's
been doing it for so long
um no i don't think he has to but what
we what i do like is if we're down in
the fourth quarter
we know we got a guy that can bring us
back i only bring us back bring us back
and win mm-hmm if we if we got a a
pocket pass or a guy that can stand in
the pocket he's tough
uh he's reliable he's a winner and when
you're couple with other guys that have
that same mentality
you don't have to feel like you have to
do it all but you do have to do your
part and i think matthew stafford will
do that all year long and more tori hold
here on the rich eisen show um i just
put you as part of the paparazzi for for
a hot minute here even though you know
we're from afar do you have any sense of
what's going on with odell beckham
or or any sense of what could be
possibly going on i was talking to my i
was talking to my buddy corey the other
day
and i don't
i think
i think odile still has
has
has it you know
um what gives you that sense would it
get you that just the general sense that
you don't lose it yeah just just
watching him you know just watching him
you know i had an opportunity to watch
that tape that his pops put out
and just watching how he moved around i
mean there was times in there where he
was you know where he's open um
but uh he's he's it's just not he and
he and the quarterback are just not
connecting they're just not on one
accord right now right but i don't think
it has anything to do with odell's
ability i don't think he's lost it yet
it's just
he just needs the ball like most
receivers do could we have ever put a
video together that long of the number
of times you were open and curt didn't
hit you
absolutely
yeah right yeah i mean but you could
have but we could have done that yeah
but but that's that's but that's part of
the game you know that but the read may
not be you initially uh but you still
got gotta run to win because eventually
you're gonna get the ball it's gonna
come back to you you got guys you got
eyes in the sky to see in the field as
well so
um it happens i think odell is a
fantastic player uh so we'll we'll see
what
what comes next with him i know there's
plenty of teams that probably would love
to have him i'm exactly right and again
like i i i
we're all got kind of guessing as to
what's what but your sense again of even
just watching the film that his father
put out
that he still has
big game ability like like odell
classic odell ability or what do you
think can you i i think there's some
moments we'll see classic odell beckham
ability yeah um but when you have those
injuries that's that takes a toll on you
um and and he's coming back from injury
uh certainly i don't know i wouldn't
wouldn't say if he if he quite had that
pop that he once had but i think there's
still enough their ability there to win
win consistently you got to put it in
his hands once you put the ball in his
hands we'll see
to our if he still has that kind of
big play big play ability he's just not
he's just not getting enough in his
hands in cleveland so then which which
team um
concerns you the most to
stand in the way of the rams getting to
where
they clearly feel they can get and have
pushed every chip to the center of the
table a la jim fossil back in the day to
go all in well there still is football i
mean so you still got to show up on
sunday yes so
um i would say right now all everybody
ahead of them because what they're about
to experience and they're already
experiencing they're going to get
everybody's best
so it's playoff super bowl kind of
mentality every week how tough is that
how it's tough it's tough but it's what
you it's that's our job that's what
you're here to do right you're here to
come and win and and have success and
have that kind of expectations on you
this is the pros
so um
that's what's going that's going to be
one of the challenges but again
because of the way they're built their
culture
their players best player on that team
is aaron donald he sets the tempo the
tone in my opinion for what they do
um as a team and he's your best player
he's your hardest working player and
he's one of your more humble
humblest players on your team so it's
about work it's about getting to a
championship he wants that he's been the
most dominant player in the league rich
for a very long time
he wants a championship a lot of the
rest of those guys also want a
championship on that team so they know
what they have to do to get there
they've been there and they know what
they have to do to get back
and i don't but not only get back but to
seal it and then bringing someone like
von miller on board who i think will be
motivated to play he just said i just
left from a four and four team and woke
up seven and one you can't tell me he
ain't motivated with another opportunity
to win his second
super bowl
so um
they got to get ready for everybody but
i think they are also ready to take on
everybody how about how crazy is it tori
holt that the guy who could be standing
in their way is tom brady yeah a guy who
denied you a second yeah if i'd walked
up to you that night in the superdome
and that february of 2002 and said you
know what i know this one hurts but it's
just going to be the first of
seven for him anyway yeah and he could
as a 44 year old
go for his eighth yeah what would you
have said to me if i would have been
like wow that's what i've said i said
wow good luck
because it's hard rich to get to the
bowl it is really really hard to do that
and the guy has done it for so long and
he's won seven
um just the epitome of
professionalism and consistency when you
look at tom brady and what he's done
and yeah i mean it could be standing in
the way but i think the rams
are prepared they've already beaten him
they're prepared you know they you know
they got some guys on the on the
defensive side of the ball
uh at corners particularly with jayla
ramsey he's really good he's sure very
versatile and when you look at tampa bay
and this is not the ram style but when
you look at tampa bay what i like what
new orleans do new orleans get up and
they face they challenge them
and then they get after tommy's ass
the rams can get out to tommy's ass
uh they've been able to be they've been
able to do it and even more so now
with fond miller as he gets continue to
get acclimated with the team and raheem
morris and his
think about the creativity he now has
even more creativity he has now bringing
on a guy like von miller
so um i think the rams are i think the
rams are in good shape
to face anyone
um
as they make their way
through the season and try to get into
the playoffs and go from there well it's
great to see you man before i let you go
tell me about your foundation brothers
foundation
hogbrothersfoundation.org you can learn
more about what we're doing there we
support young kids with the parent of
guardians battling cancer we've been
doing that now for this is our 21st year
wow so really excited about that
this past week i had an opportunity to
speak to some of our
some of our kids that we support we have
a program called kids can kids can still
achieve and accomplish anything they
want though their parent a guardian is
battling cancer
we talked to brooklyn and riley this
week who are
uh graduated out of the program and now
in university so we have a kids can
scholarship program now so we're able to
the funds that we're able to raise
we're able to help those young folks
uh through college to become what they
want to become rich and these young
women and men are incredible passionate
enthusiastic and what i love is they're
going to go and get their degree which
is like i told like we tell them that's
the best reward best gift you can give
your mom and dad whichever one is
balancing the cancer or the guardians
battling the kids that's the best reward
you can give them is be good kids and
then go and pursue your dreams and what
you want to do um so really excited
about that and not only that
they talk about wanting to give back to
their community
that's what i love it's beautiful it's
beautiful and how to be wherever they
are i tell them wherever they are right
just just just tap into your community a
little bit spend a little time with the
folks what what where can people
find more information
brothers foundation. terrence right yep
my brother terrence uh who played with
the detroit lions yeah she and i uh been
doing it for years and we're also
business partners um in the area we're
we're in the construction business and
we're helping to reshape the
infrastructure in the state of north
carolina which is really fun love it but
hopebrothersfoundation.org is where you
can find us we want to continue doing
great work um
we need the support and trust me the
support that we get is going right back
into the community and you can ask the
folks in north carolina and st louis
around they can attest to that well
we'll i'll tweet out whatever you need
or whatever you need from me cause you
know you helped me out with the run this
year absolutely in the nfl legends
community that was so much fun that was
great that was great and had a great
time opportunity to meet some incredible
people rich that you it's all no it's
all i mean
raise an incredible amount of money and
then also show that you still have your
stuff in the new rams house where you
ran
you still had it no doubt and i will be
on saturday i will be at the united way
um five five k and five a run okay uh
tomorrow is so far you're right not
tomorrow but saturday morning and you're
running in it or uh i'm i'm walking
yeah yeah i would be too yeah i'm i'm
walking i got it the knees have had
enough running bro
well i'm trying to run my way into the
hall of fame now i know that my way
i will say this i will say this um
on sunday night i mean we showed a
photograph of when isaac went in and
there's there's orlando pace in his
jacket and marshall in his jacket and
kurt and his jacket and i'm assuming
they'll all be there on sunday night as
well or best as they
can get everyone together yeah to see
isaac get his ring
um you deserve yourself sir to have it
and you don't have to say a word if you
wish to you may but no you deserve it
you deserve it your numbers deserve it
your community service deserves people
giving you that extra boost if that's
required um
you should be in there's some people
behind you with lesser numbers and
there's some people in front of you that
are already in you are in you're you're
you should be in and i say that man i
and i will look forward to the day of
that actually happening thank you i
appreciate it and i do hope that uh kurt
did the right thing and got you michael
b jordan
as big game guy has big game this should
be a big game i don't know
i don't think there's anybody is me in
there there is somebody as mooch cutting
him
yes
somebody plays much
yeah i'm looking forward to seeing it
it'll be great yeah it'll be it'll be
awesome man so thanks for coming on
tourhold thank you rich thanks for
having me brother tory holt is right
here on the rich eisen show everybody go
uh find out more about his foundation
what's that website what
oldbrothersfoundation.org
okay
holtbrothersfoundation.org everybody
should let's uh let's help raise as much
money for tory and taryn's doing what
they're doing they're doing great work
uh in their communities hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here